I do want to address something there's
there's people out there who say that
ever since I played Elvis my voice has
changed I've always sounded like this
and I can prove it here's a clip from an
interview I did 10 years ago how excited
are you to be Sebastian on the Carrie
diary I'm really excited
space so far this week on global
Saturday Night Live guest host was none
other than Austin Butler who had us
captivated with his charm wit and
Perfect Pitch vocals however it was his
touching tribute to his late mother off
the top of the show that set the tone
for a successful night but I love my mom
some of my favorite memories from
growing up are she and I watching SNL
together my mom is no longer with us
um but I've been thinking about her a
lot this week and tonight this morning
anytime you see me doing a silly voice
or making a funny face that's for you
Mom
Austin gave us an incredible range of
characters from a contestant on The
Wheel of Fortune a parody on It's a
Wonderful Life a German little child and
my personal favorite an elderly woman if
a stranger said to me come in my car
I've got candy I'd say no but if they
said I have marzipan I'd say abduct Me
Baby
God I'm so horny I'm gonna freaking
explode
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm like Niagara Falls over here my
chair is gonna freaking drown
oh ruin me Jewish Album it's ruined me I
never thought I needed to see Austin
Butler dressed up as an elderly woman
until now and although just like most
SNL episodes the night was filled with a
lot of laughter there certainly wasn't a
dry eye in the house when cast member
Cecily Strong bid farewell to the sketch
comedy show after 11 seasons
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]